for me the biggest challenge with the
centers if you go under policy and if we
were to take all the candidates and on
20 different policies let's just say
okay and you would say which one of them
do you agree with most on policies the
census is probably going to be up there
of course but there's one big factor
there you've got to have the audacity to
go out there and sit with people if you
don't
how can the people that you want to vote
for you feel confident knowing you're
going to go sit with the Enemy and
people who are really scary who can't
stand you and the more and more you take
this approach the more you come across
as a hate to say this you come across as
establishment you come across as I'm too
good you're not on my level I know
what's good for you and your daily you
said he like the entitled like he did
such a great job with covid he's that
employee Pat that thinks his resume is
so awesome he doesn't have to interview
he's just like here take that yeah I I
totally agree my favorite word in the
English language is earn
I think our entire economic system needs
to be based on earning I love that and I
think our politics need to be based on
earning and to Donald Trump's credit
he wants to earn this nomination he's
acting as if it's an open field he's
running to win Ron DeSantis is not
exhibiting the behavior the language or
even the flexibility you know this in
business right Patrick if you're not
doing well then fix something change a
message change your approach don't keep
on doing what doesn't work I mean it's
that is the definition of insane that is
the definition of insane and it doesn't
make any sense and so here's what also
what I'll kind of say about Trump which
is
people have grew an attachment with him
throughout his him literally being
president so how does one beat Trump in
a primary not that I'm like one to give
advice well I don't know you have to
talk to the new Republican party that
guess what doesn't want us to be
involved in Ukraine doesn't want open
borders doesn't want Limitless trade
deals and Patrick you hit it perfectly
if you understand the Republican base
which I believe that I understand it
better than most our podcast is the most
by proportion Conservative Republican
podcast out there Democrats really don't
listen to our show and that I wish they
would but
it's this they are a scorned community
how many times from Mitt Romney to Paul
Ryan to Mitch McConnell have they heard
the same tired talking points to see
them go to DC and let them down so
they're hyper paranoid that somebody is
going to swoop in and be purchased by
the war Lobby the pharmaceutical Lobby
and that's Trump's appeal Trump's appeal
the more he's indicted the more he's
attacked they say at least he's not Paul
Ryan yeah uh and and the more and more
we talk about this unfortunately it's
not changing it's not like they it's you
know how sometimes you Stephen A Smith
will say something and let's just say
the Lakers will make an adjustment
you're like I don't know if it was
because of Stephen A Smith but they made
an adjustment or like a coach who's a
commentator will say something or Shaq
will say I'm gonna make this adjustment
if I was a sinner and you're like okay
they kind of listen to what Jack said or
Kenny Smith said
everybody is saying this that camp has
to listen so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]